with 20 17s thor ragnarok director Taika
Waititi gave us something completely
different from the previous two Thor
films showing us places and characters
unlike anything else in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the fantastic visuals
and rapid-fire jokes were enough to
dazzle movie fans of any age but while
kids might be satisfied with spectacle
once older viewers really start thinking
about the movie there are more questions
than answers especially once you factor
in the events of Avengers infinity war
here's a spoiler field look at some Thor
Ragnarok details that only adults notice
Odin stinks at hiding things the key
villain for most of Ragnarok is hellah
the goddess of death who also happens to
be Thor and to Loki's older sister and
the oldest child of Odin hella it turns
out was banished by Odin hidden away in
a secret prison until his death abruptly
frees her suddenly the secret ain't so
secret which is actually a recurring
problem for Odin throughout the Thor
franchise as the all-father is
apparently really bad at hiding things
in the first film it was the secret of
Loki's frost giant birth in the second
it turns out there was a secret portal
out of Asgard
now here comes a daughter that he
apparently never told his sons about and
in all three cases once the secret got
out people got killed if Odin were a
little better at hiding these things as
guard might still exist today
where is SIF both of Thor's leading
ladies from the previous films are
suddenly and mysteriously missing in
Thor Ragnarok Jane Foster's absence is
explained with a single throwaway line
saying she and Thor broke up that's a
pretty casual dismissal for a star as
big as Natalie Portman but it's nothing
compared to what Jamie Alexander's Lady
SIF gets which is in fact literally
nothing aside from an actress playing
her in the drama Loki stage is
commemorating his own death SIF isn't
even mentioned in Ragnarok in the real
world
Alexander apparently had a
julen conflict but in Ragnarok she just
vanishes and nobody really seems to give
a crap
Marvel later piled on even more with
Avengers infinity war directors Joe and
Anthony Russo revealing she died
off-screen in infinity war seriously
guys
who is on dr. Strange's watchlist though
the film spends less time on earth than
either previous Thor Adventure Ragnarok
does depict Thor and Loki 'z unexpected
encounter with dr. strange who traps
Loki in a pocket dimension while he has
a chat with Thor about why they've come
to earth I keep a watch list of
individuals and beings from other realms
that may be a threat to this world your
adoptive brother Loki is one of those
beings it's a fun scene but it makes you
wonder who else is on that watch list is
Doctor Strange the Marvel equivalent of
the TSA we have a feeling we haven't
seen the last of this mysterious watch
list of his Thor god of nothing in
addition to extreme strength durability
and a lifespan much longer than that of
a human
Thor is the god of thunder which is a
key plot point in Ragnarok are you saw
the god of hammers hmm that hammer was
to help you control your power to focus
it there's no source of strength so if
his body is naturally gifted with the
power to channel lightning why is he so
vulnerable to shocks he gets shocked by
a net thrown on him by scavengers when
he first arrives on Sekar and then is
repeatedly zapped by the neck implants
placed on him by Valkyrie after she
captures him maybe those don't run on
normal electricity or something but it's
weird to see him get shocked in one
scene and then pull a lightning storm
out of the sky in another Valkyrie has a
drinking problem the first time we meet
Valkyrie she falls off her ship after
taking a big drink the moment is played
for Laughs as our other moments
involving Valkyrie and alcohol but as
the story plays out we find she is using
alcohol to block traumatic memories of
her friends being slaughtered by hella
though her addiction is mostly played
for laughs
when viewed as a whole Ragnarok actually
presents a tragic view of a woman trying
to drink herself into oblivion
where is Asgard exactly in the first
Thor film the Bifrost is the only way to
get to and from Asgard which is why it's
such a tragedy when it's destroyed in
the second movie though we learned our
actually secret portals that sometimes
allow travel to and from Asgard as well
okay fine
in Ragnarok though all bets are off
as people seem to be able to come and go
at will simply flying spaceships to and
from Asgard apparently the rules for
traveling to Asgard work however the
plot needs them to at any given moment
as seemingly anyone can just drive there
if they want so road trip anyone
infinity what now speaking of all those
as Guardians on that spaceship Avengers
infinity war begins shortly after
Ragnarok left off with the Asgardian
refugee ship destroyed by Thanos in the
carnage we see the loss of numerous as
guardians but we don't know anything
about what happened to Valkyrie or Korg
in a Q&A at an Iowa high school of all
places though infinity war co-director
Joe Russo revealed that Valkyrie
survived along with happy as guardians
so where are they well one clue might be
hiding in plain sight at the end of
Ragnarok as the Grand Master's pleasure
cruise vessel battered but still
recognizable can be seen parked on top
of the larger refugee ship it's not big
enough to hold everyone but Valkyrie
could certainly fit and maybe even have
room to bring Korg with her ears hoping